first we must stop the disease spreading
to a point weight overwhelms our NHS and
every country in the world has the same
problem this is a disease that is so
dangerous and so infectious that without
drastic measures to check its progress
it would overwhelm any health system in
the world and I've used the Italian
Health System it is excellent and the
problem is not with the health systems
it's the numbers of sufferance that's
why we announced the steps yesterday
that we did advising against all
unnecessary contact steps that are
unprecedented since world war ii they
will have an effect on the spread of the
disease the shielding of vulnerable
groups will also reduce suffering and I
want to thank everybody at this stage
for what we're all doing to follow this
advice I stress that although the
measures an hour already extreme we may
well have to go further and faster in
the coming days to protect lives and the
NHS secondly we're doing all we can and
as quickly as we can to increase the
capacity of the NHS that means more
testing more beds more ventilators and
more trained staff it means greater
support for NHS and other staff and it
means much better data and much better
technology third we must do all we can
to boost science and research we must
study this disease test drugs that
already exist and have been through
medical trials to see what helps treat
severe cases and search for a vaccine
fourth we must act like any wartime
government and do whatever it takes to
support our economy and that's the the
main purpose of this press conference
this afternoon we must support millions
of visitors and tens of millions of
families and individuals through the
coming months and to do that the
government machine must and will respond
with a profound sense of
see thousands of brilliant officials are
already working around the clock but we
must do more and faster the Chancellor
will be saying much more about this in a
moment with further announcements in the
coming days fifth we will need to
strengthen other public services that
will be under great pressure from the
direct and indirect effects of the
disease such as the effects of staff
shortages and from the economic
pressures all institutions will be under
great pressure and we will therefore
invest hugely in the people that we all
rely on them a rely on and again I want
to I want to thank all our public
servants for what they are already doing
ultimately to beat this crisis we will
need a combination of better science
technology medicine pater government
operations economic support learning
from other countries and social support
as time goes on we will learn more and
more about the disease and the effects
of our actions and while we need
national unity we also need
international cooperation and although
we now need to impose physical distance
between ourselves we must at the same
time have closer social support for each
other yes this enemy can be deadly but
it is also beatable and we know how to
beat it and we know that if as a country
we follow the scientific advice that is
now being given we know that we will
beat it and however tough the months
ahead we have the resolve and the
resources to win the fight and to repeat
this government will do whatever it
takes I'll now hand over for more on
that to wishy Cenac the chance for the
exchange
Thank You Prime Minister good afternoon
everybody the corona virus pandemic is a
public health emergency but it is also
an economic emergency
we have never in peacetime faced an
economic fight like this one I know that
people are deeply worried I know that
people's anxiety about the disease
itself is matched only by their anxiety
about their livelihoods last week
I set out an initial economic response
in the budget I promise to do whatever
it takes to support our economy through
this crisis and that if the situation
changed I would not hesitate to take
further action and that is what I want
to begin doing today this struggle will
not be overcome by a single package of
measures or isolated interventions it
will be won through a collective
national effort every one of us doing
all we can to protect family neighbors
friends jobs this national effort will
be underpinned by government
interventions in the economy on a scale
unimaginable only a few weeks ago this
is not a time for ideology and orthodoxy
this is a time to be bold a time for
courage I want to reassure every British
citizen this government will give you
all the tools you need to get through
this we will support jobs we will
support incomes we will support
businesses and we will help you protect
your loved ones we will do whatever it
takes in the budget last week I set out
the first stage of our economic response
with a 30 billion pound package of
support for people and businesses but I
also said in the budget that as the
situation involves we would take further
action and as the Prime Minister set out
yesterday we're now approaching the fast
growth part of the upwards curve he has
set out the next stage of our public
health response and so I now wanted to
update everyone on the next stage of our
economic response first the government
will stand behind businesses small and
I can announce today an unprecedented
package of government backed and
guaranteed loans to support business to
get through this today I am making
available an initial three hundred and
thirty billion pounds of guarantees
equivalent to 15 percent of our GDP that
means any business who needs access to
cash to pay their rent their salaries
suppliers or purchase stock will be able
to access a government backed loan or
credit on attractive terms and if demand
is greater than the initial three
hundred and thirty billion pounds I'm
making available today I will go further
and provide as much capacity as required
I said whatever it takes and I meant it
that support will be delivered through
two main schemes to support liquidity
amongst larger firms I have today agreed
a new lending facility with the governor
of the Bank of England to provide
low-cost easily accessible commercial
paper to support lending to small and
medium-sized businesses I'm extending
the new business interruption loan
scheme I announced a budget last week so
that rather than loans of 1.2 million
pounds it will now provide loans of up
to 5 million pounds with no interest due
for the first six months both of these
schemes will be up and running by the
start of next week and I am also taking
a new legal power in the kovat bill to
offer whatever further financial support
I decide is necessary some sectors are
facing particularly acute challenges in
the coming days my colleague the
Secretary of State for Transport and I
will discuss a potential support package
specifically for airlines and airports
and yesterday I asked my cabinet
colleagues to urgently convene meetings
over the coming days with business
leaders and representatives in the most
affected sectors to identify other
specific opportunities to support them
and they
industries including possible regulatory
for Varun's i repeat we will do whatever
it takes second as well as access to
finance business need support with their
cash flow and fixed costs
following the change medical advice
yesterday there are concerns about the
impact on pubs clubs theaters and other
hospitality leisure and retail venues
let me confirm that for those businesses
which do have a policy for insurance
that covers pandemics that the
government's action is sufficient and
will allow businesses to make an
insurance claim against their policy but
many of those businesses don't have
insurance so we will need to do more I
announced last week that for businesses
in the retail hospitality and leisure
sectors with a rateable value of less
than 51,000 pounds they will pay no
business rates this year today I can go
further and provide those businesses in
those sectors with an additional cash
grant of up to 25,000 pounds per
business to help bridge through this
period additionally I am also extending
today the business rates holiday to all
businesses in those sectors irrespective
of their rateable value that means every
single shop pub theatre music venue
restaurant and any other business in the
retail hospitality or leisure sector
will pay no business rates whatsoever
for 12 months and if they have a
rateable value of less than 51,000
pounds they can also now get a cash
grant as well i also announced last week
that we would be providing three
thousand pound cash grants to the 700
thousand of our smallest businesses in
light of the new circumstances and to
support their cash flow today i can
increase those cash grants to ten
thousand pounds taken together on top of
the unlimited lending capacity i have
already an
this is a package of direct support to
businesses through tax cuts and grants
in this financial year worth more than
twenty billion pounds and that comes on
top of the existing multi-billion pound
package I set out a budget which
included reimbursing small and medium
sized companies for the cost of
statutory sick pay local authorities
will be fully compensated for the cost
of these measures and the devolved
administration's will receive at least
three and a half billion pounds in
additional funding as a result of these
measures to provide support to
businesses in Scotland Wales and
Northern Ireland I repeat again we will
do whatever it takes third I will
strengthen our support for people's and
individuals at budget last week I
committed 1 billion pounds to support
the financial security of vulnerable
people through a half a billion pound
boost to the welfare system and a half a
billion pound hardship fund for local
authorities following discussions with
the industry today I can announce that
for those in difficulty due to
coronavirus mortgage lenders will now
offer a three-month mortgage holiday so
that people will not have to pay a penny
towards their mortgage costs while they
get back on their feet and in the coming
days I will go much further to support
people's financial security in
particular I will work with trade unions
and business groups to urgently develop
new forms of employment support to help
protect people's jobs and their incomes
through this period as I said last week
this is first and foremost a public
health emergency and I reiterate today
our commitment that whatever resources
the NHS needs it will get let no one
doubt our resolve when I said in the
budget that we will do everything we can
to keep this country and our people
healthy and financially secure I meant
it
the measures I've announced today are
part of a comprehensive coordinated and
K
in response to what is a serious and
evolving economic situation these are
only the first steps I will set out the
next stage of our response in the coming
days we have never faced an economic
fight like this one but we are
well-prepared we will get through this
and we will do whatever it takes
thank you